okay so this is the makeup video in case
you were absolute in class when we did
the pH indicator activity so I have my
lab handout and over here I have on the
Left I have sodium hydroxide and NaOH
and I want you to know that sodium
hydroxide is considered a based on the
pH scale and over here on the right
hydrochloric acid HCL and like the name
implies hydrochloric acid is an acid no
I'm not trying to figure out the purpose
of today is to not learn I'm not trying
to figure out it is sorry I'm hydroxide
didn't ask for a base I already know
it's a base I'm not trying to figure out
is sodium excuse me is hydrochloric acid
is it an acid or a base I already know
it's an acid it's got the word acid in
the title instead what I'm gonna be
doing is I'm going to be testing six
different indicators as you can see on
my page here so the first indicator I'm
gonna test is a chemical by the name of
phenol red now phenol red will indicate
if something is an acid or a base and so
it does this by turning colors let me
add a drop of phenol red into cavity
number one the little indentation
labeled number one so here we have one
drop okay and then I may also add phenol
red into cavity number two one drop is
all I need
okay and you can see that there's a red
dropped phenol red from each above now
I'm gonna take my hydrochloric acid I'm
gonna take my hydrochloric acid
hydrochloric acid solution I'm gonna add
one drop into cavity number one I'm
gonna see if there's a color change
notice how it went from like an a
reddish color to almost like an orangish
color there's a color change there that
should indicate something for me next
I'm going to take my container of sodium
hydroxide
which is a face and I'm gonna add a drop
of it in the cavity number two notice
how it to also if I swirl it up a little
bit so it's gone from like that red to
almost like a magenta color so notice
how there's a color change in not just
cavity one but also cavity too so if I'm
if I'm doing the makeup activity right
now I'm going to flip my hand out and
I'm going to fill in the observation
that I just saw
okay so on my handout I'm now looking at
the indicator by the name of
phenolphthalein and this is
phenolphthalein you can see from the
container that it's it's colorless it's
a clear liquid so I'm gonna add a drop
of phenolphthalein to cavity number
three and there we go and now I'm gonna
add a drop of phenolphthalein to cavity
number four okay may not look that
there's anything in there but there is
again it is clear and colorless now I'm
gonna take my hydrochloric acid and I'm
gonna add a drop of hydrochloric acid
into cavity number three where there's a
drop of phenolphthalein notice how the
color did not change it's still clear so
now I'm gonna take my my base sodium
hydroxide and I'm gonna add a drop into
cavity number four and instantly you can
see that there is a color change almost
a bright pinkish magenta color so that's
an observation now that now that I'm
done with that part I can go to my lab
handout and I can fill in my table on
the back and I can record that
observation
okay so now I'm at the part of my
handout that uses bromothymol blue so I
like the name implies bromothymol blue
kind of has a naturally blue color to it
and I'm gonna put a drop of bromothymol
blue in cavity number five and cavity
number six so here we go
cavity number five has a drop of
bromothymol blue cavity number six has a
drop of bromothymol blue and now like
we've done with the previous indicators
I'm gonna now first take my hydrochloric
acid sorry this is my known acid when I
add a drop of known acid in the cavity
number five I'm looking to see if
there's a color change you can see it
went from blue to yellow instantly okay
well now here's my known base sodium
hydroxide is my base let me add a drop
of sodium hydroxide to cavity number six
nothing happened
it's still blue so when I go to my table
here I can now fill in my observations
again from thermal blue in the presence
of an acid turned yellow bromothymol
blue in the presence of a base stayed
stayed blue
okay so now I'm at the part of my
handout that talks about red litmus
paper and here's a container with some
red litmus paper you'd probably use red
litmus paper in middle of school I'm
just going to use my forceps here to
pick up a piece and it says to place the
red litmus paper into cavity number
seven and also to get another piece of
red litmus paper and place this into
cavity number eight okay
now like I've done the past couple of
indicators I'm going to start with my
acid I'm gonna start with my known acid
hydrochloric acid and when I add a drop
of acid to the red litmus paper let's
see if there's a color change notice how
it's still that pink color okay so let
me go to the base now sodium hydroxide
is my known base and I'm gonna go ahead
and add a drop to cavity number eight
and you can see there's a color change
so in a acid the red litmus paper stayed
red in a base the red litmus paper
turned blue so on my hand out I can now
fill in my data table I can go ahead and
fill in my data table with that
observation
okay I'm at the fifth indicator now blue
litmus paper the fifth indicator on your
handout and I'm gonna get a piece of
blue litmus paper with my tweezers or my
forceps and I'm gonna put a piece into
cavity number nine and I'm gonna get
another piece with my forceps and I'm
going to put another piece in the cavity
number ten and like I've been doing I'm
gonna start with my my known acid I'm
gonna take my hydrochloric acid and I'm
gonna add a drop to cavity number nine
that has the blue litmus paper and you
can see an instant color change the blue
litmus paper went from a booth a blue
color to that pink color
now here's my sodium hydroxide unknown
base I'm going to add a drop of the base
in the cavity number ten that has the
blue litmus paper as well and there we
go no color change it's just wet so
notice how in a in a known acid the blue
litmus paper turned colors in a known
base the blue litmus paper stayed the
same
so on my handout I can go ahead and
record that observation in my data table
okay so here is the final indicator on
my handout this is universal litmus
paper and I'll explain the color chart
in a moment but I'm going to start kind
of how I've been doing the other ones
I'm gonna take a piece of the universal
litmus paper and I'm going to place it
into cavity number 11 and I'm gonna take
another piece of universal litmus paper
with my forceps here and I'm gonna place
it into cavity number 12 okay so let's
start with my known acid here is
hydrochloric acid it's what we've been
using this whole time it's an acid and
I'm going to add a drop to cavity number
11 and you can see an instant color
change now I'm gonna take my sodium
hydroxide which is my known base and I'm
going to add a drop to cavity number 12
and you can see instant color change
well now here's where this color chart
is helpful if I use my forceps and I
picked up the one from cavity 11 which
has been placed into the acid and I kind
of compare on my color chart now I know
it's an acid so I know it's gonna have a
pH less than 7 and it's probably
somewhere in this range probably like
maybe a 1 or so a pH of maybe 1 on the
on the scale here so there you have you
can see not only can universal litmus
paper tell me if something is an acid or
a base but I can also get the exact pH
of the chemical I'm using so let me go
ahead and put that back now here's the
the one that was dipped in sodium
hydroxide and I know it's a I know it's
a base sodium hydroxide so I kind of
just read along and it looks like it's
in the 12 to 13 range
I'm the pH scale and so you can see the
advantage of universal pH paper not only
does a test if something is an acid or a
base but
also can give you the exact pH of the
solution as well so based on these
observations I can now go ahead and fill
in the last column or excuse me the last
row of my lab handout
you